pro tools are you behaving
you record through pro tools
huh
are you on a mac
yeah of course oh it makes sense
it does make sense i just never assume
people are 96 episodes in and how i
recorded was always some just baffling
mystery always assume people use
audacity
oh hell no no you don't like audacity
well i guess
i would never use it i could probably
get away with it for this because it's
so simple it's just
you know monitor the mic however i use
this real mic uh like you're hearing me
through the little usb on zoom wait
really the the audio that i send you is
from this far superior mic
to record into audacity is a massive
pain because this is running through
external audio gear
um
but it works with pro tools
pro tools is designed for that i mean
it's pro tools you know when you go into
recording studio and you've got
interfaces and mic pres and all that you
know pro tools is absolutely built for
interfacing with that but zoom not so
much which is why
uh i had to just get a usb mic so that
the person i'm talking to can actually
hear me interesting if you recall the
old days of this show i had to use the
mic built onto the webcam the webcam
which was like
discord issues as well like you had some
kind of i still have discord yeah what's
the problem you have for discord it just
doesn't see
my
uh it always has a hard time
recognizing
the what is it the output it's like it
can't play audio through my speakers the
only way i've been able to figure out
how to
um
make discord work is apparently this mic
this little usb one i just held up has a
it has a headphone jack built onto it so
it's kind of like all in one
oh i never noticed that yeah i have to
do the same in discord it's so weird to
plug my headphones into a microphone
like i have 20 years of yeah never
thinking about that as an idea yeah and
so but that's yeah discord that's my
work around it took me forever because i
i just always assumed i couldn't do it
and then one day i was looking at this
mic and i go
there's an eighth inch jack on this
thing does this thing have oh you know
what it was i was looking on the back
and it had a headphone volume knob and i
thought
is that a yeti
just a little yellow no it just looks
like one it's an off-brand one gotcha uh
yeah this is the wave link that i think
troy also uses and
obviously i could plug the headphones in
elsewhere i can't hear myself through
this right now um
but it has its own uh sound card i don't
know what you would actually call it it
has its own sound software that comes
with this microphone that's really good
for
if you're recording gameplay or
streaming or something so that you can
separate game audio from discord audio
from your microphone audio the wavelink
software that comes with this microphone
does that it's [ __ ] awesome it's so
convenient because otherwise i was using
this thing called
something flower
voice meter i've used voice meter banana
all these different things that
basically add these like fake audio
channels it's so [ __ ] complicated and
annoying this thing is basically the
[ __ ] that i have to deal with all day
totally yeah
it's the same we deal with in the
recording studios it's amazing i've been
doing these recording sessions over zoom
with these actors on this musical
and
because we can't go into the studio
because of sag kovid rules
um we're doing like they're literally
down the street i can walk to them in
fact i went and met one of the actors in
the parking lot just to thank them and
tell them they're awesome and they
walked straight back wait so they're at
the booth
oh there's like a recording you know
there's like so are you directing
uh kind of i mean i wrote the music and
so um you know i'm i'm i'm stepping them
through it and then obviously uh you
know helping shape it and we've got the
game director and all that there's
always a few of us on the call but is
liam the game director
he's the
david gator is the uh kind of overall
creative director and brighter gotcha
and liam is sort of the executive
producer
they co-founded the company liam's
typically there too although a lot of
times it's like four in the morning in
australia so they trade off who uh bites
the bullet on that but yeah uh but
because of the sag rules um
the
only person allowed you know kind of in
proximity to the uh talent is the
recording engineer behind the glass they
don't even want another person behind
the glass since the engineer has to you
know probably get tested every day and
they go in to fuss with the mics and
stuff so they're just minimizing points
of contact which is fair so
actually the truth is i've come to
really like doing it over zoom because i
can have all my software up and when
there's a question that comes up you
just find everything i can go to the
source of where it was originally
written and and and i also you know
there's been a few times where there's
like a note question and i have like a
little piano app where i can hold i can
play the notes like one inch away from
the microphone um which because this
one's definitely not in tune and i don't
like to use this one behind me for that
purpose gotcha um so like it's actually
been pretty it's actually been pretty
good even though i was initially really
disappointed that we wouldn't be able to
be in the studio together
the reason i bring it up is because
our engineers especially at this studio
down the road
are so good at all this audio signal
path
way
routing that we're talking about in pro
tools where
we have all these different channels
like there's a backing track and then
there's scratch vocals of like other
characters in the scene and then there's
a scratch placeholder of the character
who the actor is currently you know
portraying so they're replacing the
scratch that was laid down you know by
like you know one of us on the team
um
and then there's also a click like a
metronome that's like very precisely
helps you keep track of what your tempo
is and so what is so great is
it just never fails to amaze me that
even with zoom added into the equation
it's so easy for them to create these
bespoke cocktails where it'll be like
the actor in the booth will go can i
hear
the click
pretty loud during this section but then
take the backing track way down and get
rid of all the scratch actors and i'll
say
ins can i hear the scratch actors i
don't want to hear anything they're
outputting everything different and
they'll just in one second later and so
we hear totally different mixes from
each other
um while they record that's awesome and
the fact that like that's normal that
seems really complicated
it is it is and it's
that's very that concept is very normal
for recording sessions like when i'm
conducting
um
the like an orchestra and the musicians
sometimes will say similar things like
the violins will go hey can we have a
little more click because the brass is
really loud here and we just can't quite
hear you know the the metronome and but
on the conductor's podium i'll say you
know no no extra click for me i i like
it how it is so they can individually
change the different outputs
what they're receiving and what the
balance is and all that kind of thing
but the fact that they can like easily
integrate zoom into that i just in my
mind zoom always causes problems it
would just be a matter of changing your
output right like it would just be a
matter of oh no but they're doing it to
individual people
well they're not doing it to individual
people on the call because the actor is
in the room with them but like all of
the different people on the call all
have to get the same output then we're
all getting the same out yeah it makes
sense you would just choose the
different a different output source i
would think i mean it's still
complicated i actually recorded vo last
night um and i did it
from a friend's setup uh for three hours
and
so i wasn't in a booth i had the option
to but i was like i'm just gonna go here
and do it
um and obviously the director was on a
call with me the whole time and the
thing that was the most difficult about
doing that remotely and i have also done
a little bit of vo that's been the same
as what you're saying where the director
was like on a screen and there was just
a sound engineer was that they go i
really like take b because i always do
three and then they like take b
and i was like i don't remember what
that was like i have no idea what take b
was but they don't have the ability to
do the like playback thing
where in other if you're in a studio
they'll like cut a b and c takes and
then they'll replay b for you and i was
like i don't remember what that sounded
like so he was having to mimic my b take
for me and then i would have to copy him
because they couldn't give me the
playback which was very strange how is
it a situation where they're not able to
play back what you just did i mean if
they're recording it should be right
there
i don't know i think it's just like the
way that the remote setup worked is that
we didn't have whatever sound gear they
would need to be able to do that i
suppose they did not have the ability to
output my audio
to back to me like they could only they
could hear me obviously but they could
only give me their own microphone
yeah maybe this is the kind of stuff
that i mean that zoom often complicates
because
zoom is not just listen like if i play
an mp3 on my computer right now you
won't hear it it's not like zoom is just
listening in and outputting you the full
sound from my system it's only getting
you the sound coming in from this device
yeah um and so
and anytime i try to kind of change that
i rock the boat and it's like this jenga
game that feels like it's on its last
two minutes
uh see i think you could do that with
wavelink
because i have
basically fake inputs where i could
combine desktop and microphone and then
i could swap to that
as the output for you
but you do need separate software zoom
itself one i won't do it but speaking of
audio first
dog is chewing on a bone back yeah i
keep hearing this like
she's very happy about it and then
second was last week's audio was
terrible and the issue wasn't even so it
was time for me
it was i could hear it perfectly when i
put it together
uh the thing that made it really quiet
was that the peaks were so high and i
used an auto compression for time
purposes to get it up on friday when i
probably should have just given it more
time to put it up on saturday instead um
and it meant the auto compression
lowered everything significantly because
the peaks were so blown out that it just
the whole thing got lowered um but it
did sound fine in my headphones i was
like sounds great like it was whatever
but yeah i probably should have just
given it extra time i just wanted to get
it up for everybody
it's really funny to me that i
i didn't have any awareness my phone was
vibrating and i didn't see that i never
and yeah troy was like trying to reach
us i didn't hear it at all but i guess
the table hears it
yeah that that cracked me up that that
i'm so very obviously finessing the mic
and trying to get it just right
well i think you speaking next to the
microphone when you were next to it was
part of what caused the
peaks to be so high
was that we just weren't consistent
well yeah i wish i had known until the
very very end that i could see the level
the levels on your screen i just i
should have told you
well whatever anyways most people were
happy it was great to be there we're not
set up for uh in person no i think i
think i know how to fix it next time
though
it
hey 24.
the next time that we're in the room
together it should be fine um but yeah
so mike is not here because he's not
feeling well
troy might join us
we're not sure uh probably not at this
point so austin i'm also going to have
to leave at some point because of a
fedex delivery they're going to call at
some point at some point this wasn't
going to be an eternal stream that just
goes they said they said they'll be here
between two and three but for deliveries
now sometimes i try to like tell whoever
i have a meeting with like whatever work
meeting will be like i have a delivery
scheduled for this time and it's so
unreliable they'll come an hour
beforehand or two hours late or in the
middle of the meeting even though i
scheduled it to be after so i don't know
when they're gonna [ __ ] show up
they'll be here at some point
but
we have the floor
to talk about boba fett
i also was gonna throw out there the
news that i read like 10 minutes before
uh we jumped on was a bit of an
unexpected twist that has quickly made
the rounds
uh separate from the topic you suggested
great yeah i love that i also made the
rounds oh that was awesome um the oscar
one like every composer on the planet
had something to say about that yeah i'm
glad you addressed it on on stage
uh
well i just mostly had to
had to laugh about it uh because of the
prevalence of it takes two and the
joseph ferris [ __ ] the oscars i just
can't i can't resist true the the the
moment of saying like well you know yeah
i actually the funny thing is that
if you step if you look at the oscars as
a piece of entertainment
and not as some kind of
more museum-like or educational or
aspirational piece of
of um communication but if you see it as
this is supposed to be entertaining
which clearly that's a big part of it
that's what they're trying to do i think
they're trying to cut it down for
viewership
well they're they're not really cutting
it down they're removing things so that
they can fill it with other stuff oh i
thought they were trying to make it more
shorter
i don't think it's going to be any
shorter i think it's going to be they're
just the thing is their ratings are in
decline pretty substantially you have to
change something
yeah and i i you know in the old days
like when the oscars first started like
90 years ago or whatever it was i don't
remember what number they're up to but
somewhere in that neighborhood i think
you're right the original oscars was
like a hotel ballroom
they read through you know there was
nothing it wasn't on i mean tv wasn't
even a thing so it wasn't on you know
the radio presumably i i would i would
think that the newspaper ran the article
the next day saying here's who won uh
you know it was it was a very much an
industry inside
one
paper
exactly
for a nickel
and uh so it it it was a far more humble
affair and i think
um you know
i get responding to just the the
audience
you know the audience wants to look at
celebrities
and the biggest composer on the planet
which today is you know i guess a
toss-up between john williams and hans
zimmer yeah
um
the biggest composer on the planet is
like a fraction of the audience draw of
you know a zendaya or uh or uh or name
any other massive celebrity that would
be there presenting or receiving a
nomination
you know there's invariably those
stories of like so and so who's never
won had their first nomination could
they bring it home tonight and then all
that all that interest that the audience
would have is pretty much solely on the
actors yeah um
and
and i've
it's funny i i've never had any qualm
with that half the reason why people
like scoring films as opposed to trying
to go out there and be the next billy
eilish or whatever is that you get to
you get to have an audience of millions
and live in comparative anonymity it's
like the perfect blend for people that
are not interested in being you know
sort of literal rock stars yeah and um
like john williams is the classic
example you'd be hard-pressed to meet
somebody who's more private soft-spoken
and not interested in limelight even as
much as he has been in the public eye
he's not
a public person at all
and so it's like
it's a little funny to me that the
composers are so up in arms
that this entertainment piece cut it i i
found it actually
i see both sides oh cutting editing is
nuts because it that can save a whole
movie i see both sides though because
it's like but it's also it's also
unique to film like music is a thing
that joined the art of film and had an
independent existence yeah editing is is
a piece of cinematic
artistry that did not exist until film
exists yeah it's true so it's like to me
it's as foundational to film
as anything you could name but sorry i
cut you off what were you saying um i i
get both sides i get why people are
upset i think it sucks and there are
downsides to it in that like potentially
something like that could inspire a
young composer to try film and be like i
want to be there one day that's an
aspiration it's something to strive
towards that's that's a shame but i also
completely understand when your ratings
are declining what does it serve uh to
have
a composer be awarded something when the
show's gonna get shut down because
nobody's watching it they're not making
any money like i understand both sides
of that for sure yeah and i think i
haven't watched it in years
i i haven't really either despite i used
to have like viewing parties and stuff
and over time that's just kind of gone
down and
the um
the i do think it's
um
the if we if we so at the beginning i
said if if if it's sort of a museum-like
piece of aspirational this is the art of
filmmaking and we are packaging
um a night to celebrate the art of
filmmaking in a way that the audience
can understand if that's gold number one
i think it's ludicrous to cut these
categories
if the goal is to create an
entertainment retrospective on the last
year of cinema then i totally get it
yeah and i think the problem is the
oscars is trying to kind of pretend it's
both
um because i totally acknowledge i
remember when michael jacquino won for
up
and
um
you know i've i've known him and worked
with him for the better part of 15 years
from now in the context of of our our
music education nonprofit that he i'm on
the board and he's always been on our
advisory board and very active you know
like i brought um about 20 4th graders
to his session at sony for ratatouille
um and he's all he's done things like
that with us a lot over the years it's
been very very generous given money all
kinds of things and
he
when he won the oscar and you know you
could tell that
that that's all coming from an authentic
place for him because he his comment was
something like you know for any for any
kid out there that might see this and
and they're like the weirdo who likes to
make stuff and and and or as they're the
one who is plays the guitar but isn't
really interested in learning songs but
they keep finding things that they feel
like they've never heard before so i
can't remember how you phrased it i'm
i'm butchering it but it was kind of
like if you're that kid i was that kid
yeah you know and there was something
really beautiful about the way he framed
it and i thought you know everyone
every category has had a moment like
that like some editor somewhere saw an
editor
who you know saw gave their speech when
they won for you know filling the movie
and and it really you know it kind of
put them on that path and that to me
that's always been the magic of the
oscars but i get that like that's
you know and thus i find myself in this
industry
99 of the audience is like
you know wow look at charlize is dressed
that's awesome i know yeah and i don't i
don't begrudge that i mean that's like
that stuff's fun too it is it's not what
i'm it's never been my focus but yeah um
um oh that was my aside i was gonna say
we've already tangented on ourselves i
know what was the thing you saw 10
minutes ago
epic has bought band camp uh whoa
which was uh
i didn't see that coming no way um i
wouldn't have seen that coming either
what does that what does that mean
i it's funny i've already seen a lot of
again circulating around the composer
spear pretty fast [ __ ] i've already seen
a lot of um
uh kind of hot takes uh which i found
you know somebody somebody who's a
friend somebody i don't want to make
them sound like an idiot but they
basically said
you know
i you know band camp has always been
kind of one of the great artists
bastions where you know they're very pro
artists very transparent the tools are a
billion times easier than what you have
to use to get your music on spotify and
all the rest and and it gets you way
closer to
the actual listener audience consumer
you know they they they feel like
they're buying directly from you they
have the ability to do things like pay
more if they want and they often do
because they know
an average of 82 of every sale yeah
exactly
it's very um
if you if you're
if you are above some threshold of
annual sales on bandcamp and i don't
remember what that is but it's honestly
not that high it's like a thousand
dollars or something maybe even less so
like per year
um uh of then they make your
uh
percent ten percent wow so so for
artists that are doing even a little bit
okay they make uh basically 90 of of the
sale and it to me i i love it i first
joined on to it you know give or take
about 10 years ago i buy music on van
camp for dj purposes it's the easiest
place to do it i never thought about
that yeah
to me it's awesome and what i love is
like people can send notes they can
attach notes to the purchase and it
shows up you know it shows up in your i
have like a folder that routes all the
bandcamp stuff to in my email and and
i'll go in there periodically and
sometimes people leave like these
insanely personal messages holy dick
pics especially for especially uh they
would have to do that through like ascii
art but i'm sure someone has
the uh but yeah the people will you know
will say
things like um
uh you know like i i i i'm getting
married this weekend and i wanted to
have some of your music in the wedding
so here's some extra like thanks for
that like they share these personal
things and i've always thought you know
you don't get that even though spotify
and the rest have the numbers um in
terms of audience size band camp there's
a connection to the relationship
building
it it really feels like yeah it really
feels like
i
i try to make sure that anybody that
reaches out
knows that i i read it and appreciate it
and i'll write back and and because um
that's to me the selling point of that
tool and so point point being
this friend was like oh man now it's
going to be all just like they agreed
about all those positive attributes and
they said now with epic buying it it's
going to be all about profits and i said
well wait a minute here first off
especially before fortnight epic was
known as basically creating the single
most useful tool for game development in
the world that's true uh which has
pretty indie friendly uh
like royalty terms associated with it is
free to play
fortnite is free to play you can you can
maybe quibble about the uh the nature of
that as it relates to
the the income hell of a lot of skins
but
yeah but on top of that
um the epic stores whole pitch is we
give way more money to the right groups
you're right and so i thought
i actually don't 50
uh 50 i think so because steam's 30.
steam is steam takes 30. yes sorry so
the developer would make 70. so
so i think they're like 85 or something
you might be right yeah i've done that
the wrong way around
i think i think i think epic store takes
is it like 18 percent or something as
opposed to 30.
12
oh even better so yeah i was like
they've never really demonstrated
anything remotely anti-creator in their
behavior as far as i can tell if
anything they're like just because the
epic store hasn't been able to dethrone
steam um doesn't mean their heart isn't
in the right place but the thing that
that i thought about was it's hard to
believe a big company like that has a
hot in the right place but you are right
that it should not inherently assume
that they're money hungry when they
haven't really exhibited those practices
before and to read the statement for
everybody
um
bandcamp co-founder and ceo ethan
diamond wrote in his announcement saying
bancat will keep operating as a
standalone marketplace and music
community and i will continue to lead
our team the products and services you
depend on aren't going anywhere we'll
continue to build band camp around our
artist first revenue model where artists
at an average of 82 percent of every
sale you'll still have the same control
over how you offer your music band camp
fridays will continue as planned and the
daily highlight will keep highlighting
diverse amazing music on the site
however behind the scenes we're working
with epic to expand internationally and
push development forward across band
camp from basics like our album pages
mobile apps merge tools payment system
and search and discovery features to
newer initiatives like vinyl pressing
and live streaming services so
it could just mean band camp gets
bigger
well yeah so here was my thought let's
also remember that epic recently bought
harmonix
and you're right i it made
well i i'm certain that there's a lot of
articles that are speculating in with
more analytical prowess than me but i
did find myself thinking i wonder if
they've got some kind of scheme because
the other thing that flies in the face
of they're just doing it for profit is
that i actually googled this and was to
respond properly to that person so i'm
assuming these numbers are at least
reasonably accurate i think fortnite
alone not including with what they make
from unreal engine but fortnight alone
is somewhere in the ballpark of two
billion dollars a year for them
um yeah the entire music industry is
seven billion higher
what uh in 2020 is the latest report i
could find it was 5.1 billion revenue
okay so that so so in two years they
would make they would make more than one
year of the entire music industry which
i think i googled said seven billion
that might be that might be domestic
only that number does seem
very low but i know that it's just not
as big as it once was so
the i and band camp is not like 90 of
the music market by any stretch band
camps lifetime gross which we've already
established they turn 80 percent give or
take back to the the creators or the
artists over is like 900 million so at
most this purchase i would think is a
few hundred million probably less
because band camps actual profits is
probably 100 million lifetime never mind
per year so like this was a very cheap
purchase considering
what they are able to spend uh and
relative to harmonics which makes me
think it has nothing to do with
market share or getting into the music
business it makes me think they've got
some interesting scheme
cooking scheme and not in the negative
sense like they've got some
i want to believe they've got some cool
idea yeah yeah or maybe it's like
integration on the store so that um the
epic store has music as well which is an
interesting approach like they're trying
to get music from people like you to be
on their store as well because steam
doesn't really do that or what if there
was a way to what if what if you know
like right now if i there's a bunch of
aggregator sites that you can sell music
through um band camp obviously is unique
because it's a it's a closed system like
you you sell on bandcamp and you upload
there and it's the buyer buys from there
it doesn't take you anywhere else yeah
but there's like for example there's one
called tunecore there's distrokid
there's cd baby then those those will
you know you can pay them to send it to
spotify to uh apple music blah blah blah
and it and so like tunecore has like 40
different stores including a bunch
you've never heard of because it's like
here is you know uh the like the african
version of spotify here is the
australian you know startup this and
that and they have like deals with all
these big and small
um and but one of the other things that
they've recently started doing because
people have been realizing how powerful
this is for discoverability is um you
can send out your music and specifically
choose like the time code like if i'm
going to list a
uh a song that i'm selling a single
track that's five minutes long and it's
gonna go on spotify i can push that to
tick tock and snapchat and whatnot and
say if someone searches for this they'll
find it and it will play starting at
this second so that if somebody just
types it in while they're making their
you know hopefully super viral tick-tock
video they want to use my song because
obviously there's been a lot of examples
of this like especially yeah people yeah
where a song
yeah it gets it gets vastly more plays
that way yeah than
other conventional memes but it leads to
a discoverability i wouldn't be
surprised if they're thinking and this
is i i don't know anything i haven't
talked to anybody at epic or harmonics
but if i had to guess on one possible
thing that could be really cool is if
you know i release through bandcamp and
that bakes in the ability to somehow
make it discoverable in world in
fortnite
um as like in the same vein that i can
sell and spotify by the same something
something like as a way to make fortnite
more of an increasingly in the direction
of a metaverse and less of a game what's
the biggest thing right now it really is
yeah i mean they've done concerts in
there that are far and away the largest
digital events yeah yeah that travis
scott thing was was crazy and so yeah
so first of all stats in uh real quick
so fortnite's obviously on five billion
um
other games
okay so this is combined for two years
in two years fortnite made nine billion
um in those same two years other games
epic owns such as rocket league netted
108 million
and episodes remember that they owned
rocket league yeah they acquired them in
2019 and then i think it also went free
to play
um and the guy knew that actually yeah
i'm pretty sure it's free to play now uh
and the engine brought in
221 million so
really i would have thought that that
unreal brought in at least as much as
fortnight i mean it's just so ubiquitous
but i think it may be yeah it's that
that where's mike
what you don't know anything
uh the epic game store which launched at
the end of 2018 brought in a total of
235 million between two hundred sorry
and 2019. so fortnite is by far
their biggest um and i think you're
probably right that continuing to invest
in fortnite in some way makes a lot of
sense
it's not like they don't want to grow
the other things that they have but
yeah integrating music further into
fortnite maybe they even mean to
integrate
some harmonics gameplay aspects into
fortnite
it wouldn't surprise me because i know
they're launching a new game mode soon
so like what's to say they wouldn't just
have more and more and more game modes
in fortnite potentially yeah i mean
there's nothing to stop them from in
fact this isn't a bad idea of like
instead of going to play guitar hero i
mean sure you probably would want to
support it as its own game for the
people that don't care about fortnite
but like
if playing guitar hero or rock band or
whatever was
just
an area in fortnite that you go to and
it brings along all of your various
other social aspects that to fortnight
um
that
seems like such a no-brainer for them i
mean it just keeps people it keeps
people in fortnight you know and it just
gives you and the thing is
you know this is all stuff that has
generally
been you know very pro
um
like
a lot of i started say procreator that's
too kind of broad uh it's obviously
skews heavily for the already very
famous but
all those
rock bands you know like the beatles and
and and you know
they've done so much with music
licensing harmonix has yeah in a way
that no other company has ever even come
close to in terms of exposing music
exposing gamers to
the music side of things
um
and
folding that into fortnite in some way
or another or some or whatever fortnight
becomes i feel like at some point it
won't even make sense to call it
fortnite anymore it's it's like it's
just become its own it's you're right
fortnite is its own metaphors it's ready
player fortnite
yeah yeah i
also the
apple lawsuit which epic largely lost
it's not like i won a favor with epic on
it 100 because they had their own
motives they're trying to make money but
what they were advocating for in a lot
of the documents
was on behalf of all developers and not
just
themselves um obviously apple was like
cool then any game with your engine is
off the store and they were screwed but
like that was
a lot of you have a monopoly
this is costing a lot of people a lot of
money which would be very hollow if they
weren't like we said doing the 12
split um it's not like they are
i mean they're making a lot of money and
they keep adding new fortnite skins i'm
not going to say they're not a money
hungry corporation of course they are
that's fine that's what corporations are
uh but yeah i'm just not inherently
assuming some kind of we're going to
ruin band camp and and suck the life out
of it
motive i don't think that makes sense
that's the thing if i i band camp is
like too small to be exciting to them
yeah unless they've got a creative idea
in mind i feel like yeah you know
because
one month of fortnight makes more than
band camp has made in its lifetime in
ten plus years yep
doesn't make sense so there's some
there's some that i feel like they want
it for what it is um a lot of these
acquisitions are like very unique right
now like
people are just making different plays i
feel like the streaming landscape is
just affecting things so much like i
think even our oscars conversation is
probably the oscars is failing because
it's competing with everything that i
can watch on netflix right now
in a second whereas it used to be an
event now the things that are events is
whatever new show dropped on hbo or
whatever the [ __ ] like they're just not
keeping up to date with with the
competitive nature of accessibility
right now really and
honestly they they if they wanted to
it's so funny i hadn't thought about
that but if they wanted to substantially
increase the size of the audience the
oscars all they would have to do is just
give permission of someone like
jacksepticeye to just live stream
reactions to it and not hit them with a
dmca and like 10 million extra people
would immediately find themselves
watching the audience knows to do that
yeah as much as as much as i love to
poke fun at the game awards it was i did
laugh that that um cutting music i was
like oh i guess they're taking notes
from uh from jeff yeah uh and uh and you
know but his audience is clearly
you know out outperforming theirs by a
substantial margin oh yeah he'd have one
of the fastest growing awards shows i
would think um but it's also that
i believe he
i don't want to speak on this in case
i'm wrong take it with a grain of salt
whatever i believe he cuts the things
where people aren't there to accept
awards
so i believe if you were there in person
to accept music then you would be
presented music
i don't think that's true i think that
was true two years ago at the very least
when we shat on game awards for cutting
actors
i believe his response to that was the
actors were not here that's why we cut
them that might not be true now
well but that would i could be wrong but
they know in advance you know in advance
who which categories are going to be
like i i was there
with a friend he had a game that was
nominated in strategy we did a game
called tooth and tail and it was in the
strategy game of the year nominations
we went uh he was like hey you want to
be my date because he doesn't live in
l.a he came up from san diego and said
so i said sure so we went and
uh
and uh he
didn't win and it was just kind of like
one of those where
you know
oh here are three in a row this is what
one strategy um and
it's like i don't think
his being there had any impact on
on anything and and the people that won
i don't think we're not there i think
that the run time has to be
these shows are so choreographed yeah to
you know that i don't think you can wing
it to that degree because if someone
shows up
like if you've got
oh i see what you're saying like they
might not come or they might come yeah i
don't know how they lock them in i don't
know how they
well they'd have to give them seating
right so like as his date did you have
seating right up the front of the stage
i don't remember because i think they
would place you specifically
i do remember we were seated near an
aisle which always is
suggestive of
potentially something yeah but uh yeah i
don't know
yeah i think i don't either i could be
completely wrong like i know that music
i can tell you for sure when i when i
won
uh the spike
vga for a journey
uh they ambushed with me uh they
ambushed me with that on the red carpet
on live television
uh which in the one hand i guess it was
live tv but it was in the middle of an
interview
um
and um and then during the show they
just were like oh by the way here's a
few categories uh of games that we you
know
when you did that you didn't win
that
on stage no i didn't and it was known
that it wasn't going to be the case and
i and i had won i overtly i already i
sat through the entire show knowing i
had already won and and i just now was
curious to see what other categories
journey was going to manage to win
interesting um and the hilarious thing
is i was seated inside like the entire
cast of telltale's walking dead we're
like the main competitors to journey for
all the awards that night uh oh yeah i
guess and um and they won a bunch too i
think they won game of the year in fact
i think it was one of those where
journey won like like 10 in a row and
then game of the year went to walking
dead
um
i mean obviously the last 12 months has
been a lot of it takes two but a lot of
death loop surprising amount of return
at uh
dice which i was really happy to see i
love uh return it's also like i think
ratchet won a few
you know great time to be a part of
playstation studios you know what i mean
no kidding what a great time you said
not my god of war shelf
yeah i
i really have fallen in love with it
takes two quite a bit it's brilliant
and yeah they i did i did a um the dice
podcast with the sound designer the one
guy from his light that came yes did
when they won game of the year the sound
designer he and i did a podcast the day
before
and i i was kind of like i you know
because i presented the sound category
and i i told him i was like look man i
don't know what happens but i i'm not
gonna deny that i'm pulling for you here
because i've really come under the spell
of your game uh i would love to
interview a designer on that game more
than almost any other game uh because i
don't understand how they managed to
make
10 games and put it into one
how did they scope that
their team's not very big i know they
have ea money because it's part of ea
originals but
that it's still
just amazing that they managed to have
so many mechanics that just flow into
each other
how the impression i got from talking to
the sound designer was that this game
was a master class of planning um
really good produces
seemingly like to uh to an almost insane
degree like i kept pushing him i was
almost interrogating him in our in our
podcast because
he kept making it seem like they said
yeah well we sat down we scoped it out
and you know then we did it that's not
how it works yeah it's like that's
fantasy that is truly unrealistic and
but but you know they were just they had
really good ways of tracking
metrics where if they started to fall
behind
they could tell immediately because they
had a lot of little checkpoints along
the way to sort of gauge their progress
and and they ever had to use jira
yeah i i i just use it for submitting
bugs like there are big jira fans out
there they're really something they just
love jira it's gonna be that or or
something along those lines yeah you
know it's made up in australia
really mm-hmm
so games industry you're welcome
okay that's your
the face of all the like laid-back
awesome stereotypes like the least jira
country ever for anyone who doesn't know
i didn't know what jira was before i
started working in triple a jira is a
basically a
project management tool a lot of the
games industry uses it's like
you submit what you've done for the week
or what your current tasks are
just a way of tracking what multiple
teams are up to so
you know some really design team can see
what everyone else on the design team is
currently working on what they've got
done or whatever and it's a really i to
me the secret sauce what makes it so
powerful of a tool is if i'm working
and like if i'm an audio designer and i
want to hook up a sound effect to an
animation but there's no code support
because the computer can't tell me like
the music software doesn't know that
animation is happening code has to be
able to send the signal to the music
software hey this animation is happening
if i am blocked from progress therefore
until a programmer can can take the
however long it takes to set that up
you file a thing in jira and it flags
that person and sends them a
notification yeah and you know ranked by
priority this person is now waiting for
you for a thing so everybody kind of
knows how they relate to everybody else
on a team and it's not in a wanky way
like a lot of the media companies that i
work for would have like send an email
what you've done in the week but that
was that was not for any organizational
purposes it was just so a manager could
see what you were doing whereas jira is
actually efficient like it is actually
yeah it's forgetting it's for getting
[ __ ] done and it helps them i remember i
remember on the banner saga because the
team was so tiny
the
uh john that who was like the be all
end-all everything you know he was the
programmer uh and
and sort of technical director and he
was also uh handling all the audio
implementation and everything and he
um
it was like as i would play through the
game and look for bugs in the music like
oh i started combat and the music began
with the i'm losing music and i haven't
even made my first move you know like
little things where i i could find it
you know he would always say please
please think carefully about your rank
as we got to the end and they were
starting to really run out of time and
every hour he spends is super precious
and he has to decide whose mouth to feed
is the most pressing
you know
the ranking of this is game breaking
meaning it cannot ship with this versus
it would suck versus this is a luxury
item you know versus this is a you know
this is a month one patch level like
this is definitely not please please be
very very honest with yourself and with
me about where this lands in that
because i just only have so much time
and it was the first time i ever worked
so closely with someone who made me
realize
just
like my place in the pecking order and
just how
livable certain bugs have to be
you know because there's just only so
much programmer support to go around and
and as your game gets bigger the
exponential needs expand and so
people just have to you know everybody
thinks their problem is the biggest so
the art department says oh these
textures loaded yeah loaded slowly and
it looks horrible the game can't ship
like that and it's like yeah but it
still loads it still runs yeah you know
these people's bug the game doesn't run
yeah
we just simply have to prioritize that
yeah it's complicated stuff but jira is
i'm i don't know what most companies use
for bug reporting but jira is also good
for i don't know for qa
very handy stuff
all right so before we go boba fett i am
i'm very mixed i feel like
like everybody else the best episodes
were the mandalorian episodes yep um
i felt like they seemingly
inadvertently made a boba fett show by
creating the new character of the
mandalorian
like the stoic guy in that armor and
he's mysterious they basically he's just
boba fett he's bro
they made boba fett redundant
yeah and then they not just redundant
but then they changed his character
so substantially from this like now he's
the ruthless bounty hunter with
apparently a heart of gold who like
wants to serve the people but for no
reason austin it drove me nuts i [ __ ]
hated it so i'm in agreement that i
liked the mandalorian episode
a lot actually um
and i continue to like mandalorian
but
the boba fett stuff was like i have no
stakes in
anything that's going on with you or or
why do you care about these people
who tried to kill you uh i don't i just
don't understand and i was so frustrated
by the ending because um
spoilers
leave now spoiler warnings spoilers
spoilers go away spoilers
cad bane is one of my favorite star wars
characters ever
and i was like [ __ ] yes this is so cool
i love the way he looked i love the way
he sounded
he's the original actor the original
voice actor super cool and
they
have cad bane winning a fight against
boba fett as he should
uh logically and then for some reason
boba fett is like no i must live for my
people and then overtakes and it just
makes no sense what was the character
development why did you kill cad bane
for this reason like it i don't
understand anything they chose to do
with boba fett i also find him boring so
it's like
it was very baffling and did you see um
watch seinfeld
yeah i've seen psycho you remember the
one where where uh
george
gets the little rascals you know like
those little yeah things that you can
drive around in it's like you can't walk
well or whatever that
like there's the episode where he he has
the one and all the people are chasing
him at like and there's people
pedestrians walking past someone said
you know
chest scenes in boba fett as as depicted
as seinfeld
it was also like
so many of the the
the world was empty
um i thought that the scooter gang was
atrocious just so lame and
didn't feel very
i don't know i have no sympathy for them
because they're just caricatures um but
it was mostly like my issue was mostly
with the ark like i just didn't
what was this what was i supposed to be
invested in i don't understand the one
thing that really gave me hope early was
i i thought it was cool i liked the
tuscan raiders thing as an idea i liked
the idea of showing more of a kind of
culture and not just sort of generic
desert barbarians but the idea that they
they're kind of like this religious
society and he and you know he he kind
of earns their respect and then we learn
more about them and then and then when
they get slaughtered it's sort of like
oh [ __ ] that that
that would that would hurt him he's just
lost this sort of family that
arguably stockholm syndrome but he kind
of came to see as his extended family in
a way and
in a way if they had if they'd committed
to that as the entire seasonal arc sure
you could have had something potentially
really special that does that magic
formula of
it leverages the the member barry's
nostalgia of oh tuscan raiders but then
it actually has a person
yeah whom we're not supposed to like
like they do awful stuff
and and does does do surprising things
with them and i think that you're right
that it almost feels like they tried to
make it game of thrones but they tried
to do it in one season you made him this
this king i guess and then you're like i
have to save my people
this happened way too fast for me to
believe any of your investment anyone's
investment in any of it there were also
just a lot of weird stuff happen in that
show like
he gets out of the salak pit
with the armor why does he go back to
the sarlacc pit to find his armor it did
feel almost like
the right like there were different
writers i didn't check to see who what
but it did almost feel like didn't you
see earlier episodes very strange
i love i i really liked that scene
because i he also has my favorite star
wars ship like i love the way it sounds
i love the way it looks it's so cool i
don't remember when they're calling it
now stop fire slave one it's not called
slave one anymore it's is it not no they
changed it to like
st firestar firestar i think it is
um
make sure that's right who knows because
yeah obviously i'm used to calling it
slave one
it is
ship
everything on google still says slave
one but yeah they are you know
fire spray is what they're calling it
that's the type of [ __ ] correct they are
now they never refer to it as slave one
anymore i believe they've like
officially tried to distance themselves
from the name because they find the word
slave to be problematic is what i'm
assuming
uh so it's now called fire spray
um
in any case i love that ship i love the
sound design of that ship i think it's
[ __ ] awesome so even the things that
i thought were cool i was still like
wait a minute what there's also that one
part where he like meets with all the
other leaders
and he was like make sure you don't do
anything blah blah and they're like we
weren't going to
and then he's like great and it's like
triumphant you didn't accomplish
anything you just went to a group of
people like it had stakes and they were
like we weren't going to do anything
anyway what it it's [ __ ] weird it is
it is odd uh
considering
that uh even though it's not perfect
mandalorian broadly speaking
has
did mo
a lot more right than not i agree i i'm
in agreement that mandalorian is not
it's not perfect they had things i
didn't like about middle orion but i
felt like it was so much better than
boba fett because i
i care about mando and i care about
little baby yoda
and
i didn't care
about boba fett i feel like they like
undid the things that i liked about him
i just didn't
it was truly the one thing that i was
intrigued by that i thought
it was presented as a spin-off show they
they introduced the character of boba
fett
at the uh you know towards the end of
mandalorian
and then he gets his own show that's
like a tried and true tv tradition going
back decades
but then because there were two episodes
that just overtly didn't even have boba
fett in them i found myself going maybe
they're experimenting with a new format
where it's not really spin-off it's one
show that kind of pendulum swings
between sort of central leads and that
we're gonna bounce and i thought that
could be an interesting format change
that the streaming era
enables that tv traditionally wouldn't
have i think but i don't think they
actually are doing that that was just
well no i think that they did say in an
interview somewhere that they looked at
it as mandalorian 2.5
more so than its own show which makes a
lot of sense
yeah
which could be like that notion
because i always liked you know back in
the day
um i remember i
fell i i never watched buffy and angel
when they were on the air but then when
they were on dvd i discovered and fell
rapidly in love with them and i remember
binging through the dvds of buffy and
then going
i guess i should watch angel now and so
you start angel episode one which
took place concurrently with buffy
season four
and because they ran in parallel so then
later being the nerd that i am i went
and watched all 12 seasons of the two
shows again
but i had looked up and created a
spreadsheet of the air dates because
every now and again very nutty oh i'm
not ashamed
um every now and again there would be
like a new episode of buffy and then not
a new angel and then the next week would
be both new episodes and that or that
kind of thing wait they'd like to skip a
week
just due to presumably production
schedules and things like that like
every now in other words they weren't it
wasn't just this lock step every single
week at least when i looked up the air
dates it wasn't always you know the same
night the new episode or whatever for
them tracking one to one which meant
that every now and again if you want to
keep the order correct
you would have to watch like two in a
row of one and then go back to the back
and forth and was that it was
it was because the shows fairly
regularly had back and forth between
them where
like the premises that angel takes place
in la and buffy takes place in some sort
of you know uh uh bakersfield-esque
uh small town somewhere inland in
california and
uh there you know a character would show
up in l.a on angel and then and then
they'd like carry that story back onto
buffy and it wasn't extreme it's not
like
the two shows were running in interwoven
plots the whole time but they did it
frequently enough that it was worth the
hassle i felt to watch them the way that
live audiences were watching them back
when it was a live new episodes show
yeah and so the idea that that they
would go the next mile with that with
this with with mandalorian and boba fett
where
it's like one super show
was exciting and then by the end of both
i was like nah they're not doing that
yeah
i mean and that they could have done
that potentially with like if they did
like ahsoka
yeah maybe i would be down for that but
i feel like boba fett for the most part
was very forgettable and it's a really
interesting thing that
if if you were to ask me who the main
antagonist was for majority of that show
i would not be able to tell you
i don't know i don't know what our goal
is and i don't know who our big bad guy
is
our goal was to have him ride the rancor
i think that was clearly that was that
was the direction because that's like a
thing in a writer's room that you have
to be like what is the goal
who is big bad guy
what's the character awk i don't know
the answers to any of those questions
i'm sure i could like think about it a
little bit harder but the fact that i
can't as watching this whole show that i
can't immediately be like probably this
i don't know what you were trying to do
i have i have no idea um it also like
had some pretty bad
uh visual effects and
i don't know the pacing of the action
scenes with those scooters that's the
seinfeld thing like i was astonished
because
i always thought of robert rodriguez he
directed that i remember looking it up
because i thought this who did this uh
and
you know this is a director who's no
slouch um now i haven't seen any of his
films lately but certainly back in the
earlier days of his career he made some
films that are essentially classics
and
but
watching that i was like this is it
feels
intentionally deliberate
deliberately and and very slow paced it
it's and and again i it's an odd
art direction choice to do this famously
kind of run down desert planet and have
these bright shiny colorful i said it
it almost feels like
a prop from a different
show
yeah i agree it doesn't fit stumbled in
they didn't fit at all i i really liked
chrysanta or chris santon
the wookie thank you very cool like
there was some things that i was like
that but even then like that scene where
he rips him out of the back to tank it
it felt like a turn-based strategy fight
where
one would take a hit at him and he'd
knock them away then he would turn to
the next one who's standing there
waiting it's like final fantasy tactics
everybody gets their moment we're kind
of chipping away 100 i don't i don't
feel like you can even assign that much
to the directors on this nor on
mandalorian i wonder if it's like budget
restrictions or something we don't know
about in part because i thought that
bryce dallas howard's episode of
mandalorian season one was my least
favorite episode i thought that was the
the worst episode of the first season
i've been to lauren however her episode
was the best so i feel like it's like
maybe the directors are a lot more
restricted than we think they are we're
assigning too much to them it's like
it's about what script you get and what
budget you have for your episode less
than even the directing of the episodes
because seriously she went from the
worst episode to the best episode um of
probably either show i think that
episode of boba fett is probably the
best episode of mandalorian as well but
she had the worst one so it's like i
don't i think that they probably are
working on weird restrictions and i
hadn't thought that that's normal for tv
totally and i know that a lot of people
do like it like obviously these are my
own opinions i have no beef with people
liking the show but my my consideration
was that maybe
disney was trying to make these
especially because tatooine looks so
empty all the time
maybe they are trying to make it on more
of a budget than i would have expected
or
covered made things very difficult for
them
it also could be that this was you know
this was rushed
uh yeah you know like
like for example uh
dropping the [ __ ] like when they
greenlit all these shows you know to in
the pipeline it was before the pandemic
yeah once the pandemic hit and everybody
realizes oh [ __ ] we've got a very
captive audience how much crap can we
get out into the world as fast as
possible i have no clue if
if um
uh if that is part of the story here uh
at all because i know we're in a time
where
i mean how long has it been since the
last season of stranger things like
we're in this time where people are
accustomed to letting things take
however much time they need i mean it
was like two years between seasons of
game of thrones yeah so the rush is
unnecessary the audience i think sticks
around for you
if you have something that's special
star wars saturation is also a thing
that
surely they learned a little bit from
solo
that maybe there's too much star wars
like boba fett i felt personally was so
bad that i was like i'm not watching
anymore and i'm no longer watching star
wars tv i'm out i can't resist the fact
that they have you and mcgregor coming
back that's that's what everyone i've
said to says everyone's like yeah but
obi-wan and i'm like
yeah i know also also bear in mind that
the next show other than that is the
rogue one show and that to me rogue one
is far and away the best thing star wars
since disney took over i agree it is the
single triumphant like i think that
movie can go toe-to-toe i mean other
than clones i think the last season of
clone wars was really good
yeah but that's them like not fixing
what isn't broken uh you know what i
mean like yeah the clone wars starts
it's always good ages ago yeah but that
season was really good like that what
they did do you actually haven't watched
it yet it's great i've heard that though
i heard it was terrific yeah but i think
it was very much a get the band back
together type show not a the thing with
obi-wan is like i hate that like the
draw is there right like i know that i'm
like [ __ ] and
and i i
it appeals to me but i'm like
i should be watching so much more good
tv or good movies that i don't watch
because i'm like i don't have time why
am i watching stuff that is bad like i
sat through the whole of boba fett
and i only liked two episodes and for
the most part i was like this is bad and
also like as a writer i feel like i
should be watching [ __ ] that's really
good to learn from like sopranos or the
wire like i should be watching that
stuff and so i'm like well are they
going to get me because it's obi-wan
when i'm like i should be watching all
this good tv why do i keep
falling for the bad tv and it's mostly
because my friends keep talking about it
and i'm like like they're like watch it
dude you have a star wars podcast
i basically have a star wars podcast and
it's like when i was uh watching the
final uh episode because i wasn't even
gonna watch it everyone was like just
watch it trust me just watch it you
specifically should watch it because
people know how much i love cad bane um
and i i had multiple people i had to
text when i was done and somebody called
me immediately to see my reaction and i
i felt like one of those
angry star wars twitter fans where i was
like [ __ ] this show this is [ __ ]
trash they're dead to me i'm done it's
garbage and i was like oh i'm not that
person what is this doing to me and why
do i keep indulging in it like i just
need to stop it's so hard though you're
right
house throwing thank you
flamingo and i know that they could
bring him back to life because it's star
wars but it doesn't matter the fact that
he lost that fight at all
for some fake character growth for boba
fett that i never had any investment in
it's not that he died it's the way that
he died is so ridiculous that i was just
like this is what you do with this
character for this purpose are you oh my
god
yeah when you when you
anytime you have characters do things
just to advance some sort of disembodied
plot idea yeah very well you just need
them you're like moving them around like
chess pieces and and they're not they
don't the characters aren't sort of
alive in their own right yep you're
almost certainly making something bad
it's just yeah but it was nuts because
that episode like ign gave it like a
nine i know people have different
opinions and they're totally welcome to
just very hard for me to
hard to see that it's just hard to agree
hard to even see it in there
well if you want a recommendation of
something i watched this um i kept
seeing show up on the homepage this
korean high school zombie show all of us
you mentioned it to me in uh vegas
did i i don't even remember doing yeah
you did i
have to say i love that [ __ ] what's it
called all of us i did all of us are
dead it is a it is a melodramatic high
school like
you know
do you like so-and-so but what is
they have a boyfriend like it's that in
a the context of an insane zombie
it looks well shot so is it is it a
comedy
i would call it a dark comedy but it's
pretty it
it's absolutely a dark comedy because
there are some times that it it gets
very bleakly hilarious
but it's not without
real investment and real stakes and real
characters and and they do some things
there was a moment where angela got
teary-eyed when we were watching it like
there's some moments where they do the
classic dark comedy like the cone
brothers are so good at this where they
lure you in with all this kind of
macabre sensibility and humor and then
they sneak in something that's really
earnest and you're like oh [ __ ] i wasn't
read i didn't i wasn't prepared for this
you know and they catch you un
uh sort of disarmed so
i
really
liked it i thought they did especially
because the zombie
genre is seemingly just so saturated
also yeah um they did some things that i
thought were really novel and they also
did things that felt like this is one of
the first
zombie
shows that feels like it has a realistic
uh portrayal of how
you know a government in the military
could could react
um
it it it didn't feel
um
like it it wasn't
it wasn't a
in three seconds all of the world is
destroyed and it's now mad max like
the trailer that's interesting vaguely
looking at so far has not shown a single
zombie i guess they show up at 40
seconds
into this trailer but it it does look
like a lot of
okay it kind of it i don't know when
they wrote and produced it but it
because it kind of feels like one of
these things that
that um just got lucky with its timing
because in so many ways there is a
um
slight suggestion of kind of parallelism
of the zombie thing with the covet
pandemic oh yeah um
they don't they don't make a big thing
of it but i mean the show clearly was
shot during the pandemic because they
they literally you hear them mention
covet in the show at one point like a
news reporter
you know make some off-handed comments
they clearly shot this thing recently it
wasn't like it was produced and waiting
for distribution or whatever but what i
don't know is when they wrote it in
other words i don't want to venture that
it was written
you know conceived of written produced
directed blah blah blah all
under the pandemic although it may have
been it doesn't feel explicitly like a
reaction to the pandemic so much as just
something that kind of
runs with themes
but i loved it the the actors are great
and there's something very specific that
happened in that show that i really want
to talk to
uh uh talk about with with you guys on
on here um because angela and i got into
a kind of spirited argument about one of
the characters and it made me zoom out
and think about this concept of
just bigger questions about the nature
of writing that i think you know
are two estranged gentlemen and yourself
would all have really interesting
opinions on
um
so help me remember
next time
to bring this up because i don't i don't
need to spoil anything about the show to
just ask this abstract version of the
question
yeah that was the thing coming from
mandalore or boba fett which is you know
seven weirdly varied actually there was
an episode that was under half an hour
i'm pretty sure it was like quite
could be yeah yeah which i guess is like
part of the streaming service freedom is
that you can have lengths however i'm
working on one right now that that's a
netflix series that's literally there's
like 20-minute disparities between
episodes in some cases um because it's
like tell the story that's right
uh you know they they that fully and
they are fully encouraged to do that by
netflix so
um
anyway yes help me remember that
that there was a thing i wanted to
float that this show kind of got me
thinking about i will float that um yeah
i assume that we'll be back with
everybody
next week i don't know
i guess we'll figure it out troy clearly
was not able to join us which is you
know all good
um hey we spoke about boba fett i'm glad
i know but i felt like success from what
we had said you were more positive about
it than i was
it was one of those where i was i i i'm
well i tend to be a little bit of a
rose-tinted glasses kind of guy about
things so i kept waiting for it to kind
of stick the landing i was like look i
don't actively hate it
my checklist of things that i was
raising an eyebrow about kept growing
with every episode yeah but but i didn't
let go of the belief that they could
somehow magically pull it out and it
could end in some super awesome way sure
especially because the mandalorian
episodes gave it the shot in the arm
like ooh they must have some really
[ __ ] awesome thing cooking here sure
and and then and then it kind of was
like
sometimes you just have to let it go
points though we glossed over this
points on big improvement on the deep
fake thing the holy [ __ ] yeah they got
way better because they hired uh someone
who made like a youtube video who
corrected it previously right also the
fact that his voice was completely
synthesized
you know i i heard something
did we talk about that here
why do i have a weird deja vu about that
um you might have i don't know who knows
what we [ __ ] talk about
because i thought it was
performed just it wasn't by mark hamill
um i don't know the article that i saw
said that it was entirely made up of
like digital let me see um
that seems voice that seems utterly
impossible given my understanding of the
current state of that tech
like voice synthesis like text-to-speech
is really getting sophisticated but it's
pretty monotone still all things
considered and you
but i don't know i mean these shows like
the visual backdrop thing the visual
screen projection thing i mean this show
these shows have been an incubator so
it's so good yeah it's so cool so
this was from
slash film and it says
it's not hamel's real voice the audience
is hearing obviously instead the output
of a highly advanced voice synthesizer
called respecher
um it was first uncovered in disney
plus's own feature at disney gallery the
mandalorian where experts explained that
it's a neural network you feed
information into and it learns oh no
that's how the world ends from old
material featuring hamill's voice around
the time the original star wars came out
well there you go
if they go on to say the decision seems
somewhat puzzling given hamill is an
incredibly talented voice actor in his
own right plus the fact that he always
seems willing to collaborate with the
franchise his voice is so different now
though like he's
it's like with carrie fisher you know
yeah you listen to 19 year old yeah i
mean she was literally a child in the
original film and
her if you listen to her on family guy
in the last few years of her life it
took me a long time to realize that was
her on family guy yeah um and
so yeah that
i think with mark hamill the difference
is less striking but he definitely
doesn't sound like the
boy i don't know i mean maybe he can
maybe he can mimic that but like his
voice is is very very different um
so like the speculation in this article
on game rant is whether it's down to
schedule conflicts budget reasons or
simply the studio's interest in test
driving this novel software at the
highest level disney has still not
addressed why this particular choice was
made i don't think hiring mark hamill to
do it would fix
what you want it to
um yeah so
i mean look it seems like it was
i my only thing with the deep fake was
just sometimes i feel like they link it
on his face more than they needed to
almost like they were trying to show it
off in ways that you're like you could
have just cut away from that one you
know you didn't i really thought it was
gonna be like a three minute scene
uh
just to show the you know the
relationship and the and you know let it
let it
flex its its improvement over you know
that's like the one glaring problem in
rogue one a movie that is otherwise i
think so amazing is like the leia thing
was just so
horrible um and it was so unnecessary a
shot of her from behind
where you open up and you see would have
been so much more exciting it would have
been it would have it would have it
would have solved the problem and made
it more filmically satisfying at least
to my taste um but um so i you know i i
i get them wanting to show you know some
kind of look how far we've come but the
fact that he was like the central
character for a while i i thought holy
[ __ ] they're really
they're all in on this yeah you know i i
give them credit for courage uh you know
because they took a beating twice in a
row on that stuff with the leia and then
the bando one it was like
this has not been popular and and they
are like you know what how about
how about in response we will show you
by far the most screen time of this that
we've done and it did better but it's
and it worked it i mean it did it did
work a lot better yeah i wish they'd cut
it back a little bit like like you said
in every instance just do a little bit
less and we would all feel more
comfortable but also
let characters die as well like i don't
think that we need to see them all the
time i think luke in this context made
sense and it was cool to see him the one
issue with that neural network voice
performance is that he was just so flat
yeah like just so stoic in a way it made
him sound like
um it made him sound like he was deeply
talking down to grogu where it was kind
of like one day you're gonna grow up but
because yeah adults don't speak
naturally to they they tend to speak
naturally to each other and you could
tell very strongly when someone's kind
of talking down to a kid and i kept
thinking like
this is someone you are proposing to
train as a jedi yeah it feels weird
who's like 100 years old
who's like 100 years old and sort of
related to the greatest of them all you
know the ultimate jedi it felt weird to
felt like i was looking at a very
strongly parent child as opposed to
student
student in that teacher yeah that could
have been intentional or it could have
been an issue with with that technology
respect or whatever it is
but yeah it is probably some some blend
of the two but in any case it was it was
there was a lot to like although it is
funny to me how
yeah i want to be clear i didn't hate
everything in the show
i just had a problem with like the lack
of character arcs
motivations
and like a clear antagonist like
structural issues with it i obviously
have a clear protagonist yeah
just like
there was things that i was like oh neat
oh interesting like like i said i liked
the
the ship in the salak pit while
simultaneously being like this doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense how did they miss
this oversight but i was like it looks
cool and it sounds cool like it's not
like i was like old trash i just
well and let's uh
we can end it on a on a high point even
though i thought her character was
completely useless and you know gave her
absolutely nothing the the woman the
ming na nguyen yeah who had been on
agents of shield first off she's almost
60 years old incredible
incredible which blows my [ __ ] mind
um but on top of that i've never
realized until halfway through the show
that she was the original voice of mulan
like 20 years old
and i was like
that's cool
i like her and i like her design however
i think their two characters
are too boring the two of them together
is two people who are just very stoic
badass you need a little bit of flavor
no actually
boba fett wasn't badass he kept getting
his ass kicked she was the one yeah no i
mean in personality not in action like i
mean like they're just
they you almost could have flipped them
they're not they're just
not different enough like they're just
both very
i agree you know they're they're they're
action figures yeah what i was gonna say
is the one thing that makes me laugh
about these disney shows is that you
know disney's obviously are the the star
wars shows is that disney is obviously
trying to mastermind some star wars
equivalent of the mcu because there's
never been
non there's there is no non-canonical
star wars
film or tv that exists i mean unless you
unless you count like
you know the very fringy home video like
parade the ewok
you know caravan of courage or the star
wars holiday special but like there are
nine star wars films that are equal
on tv
boba mandalorian yeah obi-wan they're
using all the same actors i mean they
even you like the guy who plays bowfed
is literally the django fed actor from
the prequels yeah
so there is no equivalent to like sony
made sam raimi spider-man and then the
mcu spider-man there's the brian singer
x-men movies there's no equivalent to
that in star wars like
it is all star wars star wars is one
it's just the books
but they as soon as disney bought it
they said none of those count anymore
yeah um and even though they keep
referencing like things that are kind of
hinted at which parts count and which
don't then yeah like like the like the
wookie uh christin
yeah like he's was not originally he he
was introduced i think in a con
and so
but point being um
the
the thing that is fascinating is
it feels like the shows cannot possibly
be part of the same canon as the sequel
trilogy because the shows are so clearly
off the back of return of the jedi they
take they feel like the first few
episodes of mandalorian felt palpably
like they took place
other than the fact that it was weird to
me they spoke about jedi as some ancient
long-lost thing and like five seconds
earlier the jedi were responsible for
the ending the empire but but the
setting that aside it felt like a thing
that takes place very understandably
after the fall of the empire the
galaxies and chaos you know that that
image in the pilot of mandalorian of the
stormtrooper helmets mounted on spikes
and like that felt like yes this this
understands its place in the timeline
and it's doing a beautiful job
and then the but the jj abrams
ryan johnson
they feel like
fan films to me now and these shows
exacerbate that further
what i have done personally has just
decided which of the things i want to be
canada which i don't and i i can and
then pretty much like i've said to to
other star wars fans i know i'm like
i've just decided that bubba fe isn't
canon i prefer the version in my head of
the boba fett that exists
what you've done to him here is this
like whole new character
nope
it's extended
but you're allowed to make those choices
i'm wrong obviously that is there canon
but it's like what you're you can take
whatever you want from from i'm fine i'm
not going to take this
no no absolutely i always i always yeah
i i have no
um
i have no qualms i don't even remember
what happened in rise of the skywalker i
what a what a
film what a mystery what a fantastic say
the least yeah that's the thing they
they
those how they connect
um makes no sense and the funny thing is
the argument could be made boba fett
should never have had a show
because the thing that made him a fan
favorite he has like four lines in all
of star wars he's this he's this
you know whatever you imagine
ruthless bounty hunter to be he's that
the version in your head he's that guy
because there's nothing to contradict
that and his mysteriousness was the
essence yeah it's the same reason why
people initially complained about
learning the childhood of anakin
skywalker because darth vader was better
served
with out knowing that now i they did a
great job with darth maul
like darth maul has been delved into in
rebels and in clone wars and darth maul
is still [ __ ] cool
yeah that well that's the thing i'm i'm
not one of those i never was a
the like darren corbin i would always
get into arguments where i always said
you know when i remember when he had his
son
i said this is always my challenge for
parents is
how are you going to show them star wars
do you go one two three four five six or
then seven eight nine or is it four five
six one two three and darren goes
there are only three star wars movies
like so defiantly the kids love the
prequels and that's like that's who
george said they were made for like look
i still think those movies are
massively flawed massively massively the
thing is but they have a lot of heart
that also three
is so so much better than one and two
yeah that that it it's like in a way
everything that mattered from all three
is in three
um yeah and so to me that
there's a very unequal distribution of
quality across the prequels because
trans menace is large that's why the
so-called machete
watch order where you go four five
two three six
is supposed to be like i tried it once i
did it the day force awakens came out i
spent the whole day at home watching
four five two three six and then at
midnight went opening night and saw
force awakens and it wasn't my favorite
day of my life
the high of being there and seeing a
crowd go down the street we're at the
cinerama dome hollywood arc light the
line went down the block at two in the
morning that was cool and and you know
they at the arc light they had the big
marquee of all the like 24 screens of
what they're showing and for it to be
one solid wall of the force holy [ __ ]
not a single screen showing anything
else i saw that movie in cinemas six
times
wow that's second for me behind the dark
knight which i've seen i think 12 times
which is just because every time it
shows anywhere i go and see it
yeah it's i was so excited about the
prospect of force awakens i was even
though it is very similar to a new hope
which is my favorite star wars movie it
it rehashes a lot of that i was so
excited about things that introduced
that i remember just spending like hours
at bars talking with friends about like
what does this mean what is this going
to mean what is this going to mean and
then it all crosstown jj abrams was
asking someone else to say that same
[ __ ] question ryan johnston too and
then it just kind of all
yeah
a lot of people love them more power to
you
oh believe me i would give anything to
be one of those people i would love to
love them i i would love to love them
and i don't hate them you know there's a
lot of craft that goes into a film like
that i don't hate them like a lot of
people do i'm not out here making
youtube videos about why i think they're
garbage and there were things like even
in the lost jedi which i conceptually
did not love that i thought were some
very [ __ ] cool
star wars moments like that light speed
jump even though i get that logically it
doesn't make a lot of sense was visually
so [ __ ] cool
i saw there's a great youtube channel
that's like
really really deep dive nerdy star wars
stuff where you know he'll he he i kind
of remember the name of the channel so
we could there are so many of them um i
know let me see if i can find it really
quick before we jump off the the um
he'll look at like a shot of the fleet
from you know uh return of the jedi
where they're just about to
transport into um
into attacking the death star and
there's you know background in the
background there's like blurry just
miscellaneous rebel ships in the fleet
and so he'll do a whole youtube video
where he'll zoom in on this one and go
what is this ship and he'll show like
the research and trying to figure out
what was the 3d model and then he'll
make his own 3d model
like i've decided it's this and he just
he just
makes he makes this [ __ ] up but from a
place of you know major reverence and so
he did a whole video he did one that i i
died laughing where he goes everybody
shits on stormtroopers for how
inaccurate they are so i decided to just
crunch the numbers
and
he took the opening battle from a new
hope where there where the stormtroopers
are in an open battle with the rebels as
they are capturing the tantu iv leia's
ship the very opening scene from any
star wars movie ever seen by any
audience he says let's use this battle
as the metric and he counts the number
of shots the rebels take and relative to
the number of storm troopers they kill
and
and the reverse
um and then compared it to real world
like military accuracy statistics and
came to the conclusion that
stormtroopers are like
inhumanly accurate because in reality
it's [ __ ] hard to hit a target yeah
that's moving in a battle yeah and he
presents all of his data and it was
hillary that's really cool
his but the video that i'm uh thinking
of that he actually made me come around
because i kind of got a little bit close
to being one of those
annoying star wars nerds that was like
the whole light speed thing kind of
breaks star wars if that's that powerful
it kind of undermines just done it a
million times yeah and and he presented
a rebuttal to that he was like i
he goes the ship first off that they
used the general point he makes which i
thought you know
fair
the ship that they use is like the
largest ship the rebels have ever had
um
and it's also aiming at the largest ship
the empire has ever had um because they
do make a point
in the very original where han solo
makes it sound like light speed
calculations are actually really nuanced
and and hard to get right and there's
like this whole thing about the
millennium falcon like you know if we do
this off if we're off by a milli you
know a nano degree in angstrom uh you
know we'll fly right into a star or
something which of course that doesn't
astronomically make sense because
space is overwhelmingly empty but yeah
setting that aside uh they make it sound
like it's not an easy thing to do and
also the fact that
it's only made possible by the fact that
they're taking a giant ship that for the
majority of the rebellion's history they
did not have they did not have big ships
like that true um
and he makes other points i can't
remember
there was some other point to it that i
remember thinking you know well i know
that yes that that han warns about not
making quick blind jumps through
hyperspace is a thing so it's like yeah
you can do it it's dangerous but but my
question is then why wouldn't people
have done it before
well that he that his art he tries to
address that um his the channel is
called ec like the the letters e.c henry
um
and uh shout out in the description
it's yeah i gotta say i
i have fallen in love with the depth of
the nerdiness he did another one on that
ep on that channel about
the enterprise d from star trek next
year yeah yeah the original klingon
vessel i'm seeing a bunch of
his his next gen um enterprise d episode
was was about how
gigantic that ship really is and then
when you compare it to the crew
compliment he goes realistically you
could wander the ship for days and never
run into anybody in the hallways
like if you just
he he kind of walks through the math of
how he gets there and it was one of
those who think [ __ ] hell you're
right this ship
like
on a on an actual real world aircraft
carrier they have more crew members than
on the enterprise d and that thing is
vastly larger so you realize like it's
actually
it's it is weirdly empty it would have
to be yeah they always portray it where
there's just flow of people everywhere
maybe there's just a lot of empty rooms
yeah it's just like all storage it's all
yeah exactly it's just a lot of storage
yeah they've got to keep all their food
somewhere you know this this does look
like a really cool channel it's um it's
it's insane there's a headline that is
about if whales fit inside of a certain
ship klingon yeah yeah that's from star
trek four wow the uh yeah this is the
thing i'm really showing my true colors
in this episode
i love that kind of [ __ ] it's true we're
talking like i i have gone full nerd in
a way at least i started by who are you
kidding did you think that you weren't
did you think that you had hidden it
from us like it was some kind of grand
secret
come on
yeah yeah i i i
i've been living a lie this whole time
know thyself
all right we should head off at this
point
thank you everybody for watching another
episode of play watch listen i'm alana
ps i'm a video game writer that is
austin wintry he is a video game
composer and we will see you guys next
week